Speaker 1: The state of Arkansas continues to
waste the time and resources of the people in
the state now by restricting school bathroom
use by transgender people under the leadership,
if you can call it that, of Republican Governor
Sarah Huckabee Sanders. They have banned CRT from
schools, which wasn't being taught in schools, and
they are generally wasting a ton of time. And now
the news is, yes, indeed, Governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders signed a new law prohibiting trans people
at public schools from using the restroom of their
choice. This would make Arkansas the fourth place
to put such restrictions on public schools. And
it requires that those that individuals use the
bathroom that match, I believe the wording they're
using is their birth sex. Alabama, Oklahoma and
Tennessee have filed similar restrictions,
although lawsuits have been filed. And this is
something that is growing and growing and growing.
Here is where I want to focus today on this issue.
It's really important to talk about the absurdity
of the bathroom issue. There is simply no evidence
that trans people in public bathrooms pose a
threat to the safety of others, whether we're
talking about kids, adults in schools, out at
restaurants, in malls, or whatever the case may
be. One of the big arguments, really, the biggest
argument that the right makes is that if anybody
can just use whatever bathroom they want based
on their alleged their stated gender identity,
it opens the door to stalking and sexual assault
and pedophilia and all sorts of different things.
There is absolutely no evidence that that is the
case. And in fact, when you look at the data,
there are widespread studies about this. Studies
have shown that trans people are way more likely
to be the victims of violence and the victims of
harassment in public restrooms than they are to be
the perpetrators. There's a 2013 study from UCLA
School of Law. It finds 70% of trans respondents
were verbally harassed or assaulted or mistreated
in public restrooms. A 2016 report by the Human
Rights Campaign found that 59% of trans people
avoided using public restrooms in the preceding
year because they were afraid of those negative
experiences. And there's a 2018 study from the
AARP, the American Academy of Pediatrics, which
finds trans people and gender nonconforming youth
are more likely to experience verbal and physical
abuse in school restrooms. On the other side of
this, there is absolutely no study that finds
that when you look at incidents of harassment,
sexual assault, etc., in public bathrooms,
that trans people are overrepresented
relative to their population. There is
just no data that can support that cause.
And then there's the last aspect to this. If
your concern is sexual assault or harassment or
whatever the case may be, it is already illegal.
It doesn't your gender identity doesn't matter,
your genitalia doesn't matter. It is already
illegal to engage in sexual assault or harassment
or stalking or photography or whatever the
case may be in public restrooms. Doesn't
matter which bathroom you're in. The gender
identity of the individuals involved also
doesn't matter. And the law is applied equally.
Whether you are cis, gender or transgender. The
law is already there and there is no evidence
that trans people are more likely to commit
sexual assault or harassment than cisgender
people. So the entire framework here is a moral
panic and fear framework. As is often the case
with right wingers, they don't have the facts
on their side because the facts aren't on their
side. And so it's based. On fear. And the idea,
quite frankly, the idea that they want to tell
you is that Hulk Hogan is going to put on a wig,
go into a public bathroom and harass little
girls. That's the idea. The image that these
folks want you to believe, it's not happening.
There is no data that backs this up as an actual
danger. And Sarah Huckabee Sanders just continues
wasting time on this complete and utter nonsense.